deuxième joueur à ma vie
quoi
[Musique]
c'est passé tant de choses depuis notre
dernière rencontre j'ai perdu mon
marteau
hier c'est tout récent je suis encore un
peu énervé
ensuite je suis parti en quête de moi
même
et c'est toi que j'ai trouvé
bon
ou est ce qu'on est si tu savais hélas
la déesse de la mort en obéit à ce gars
là j'attendais ça depuis si longtemps
je sais on s'est battu l'autre jour et
j'ai gagné non je gagnais facile tu es
sûr de toi t'as perdu
c'est tout
as garde est morte et elle remettra
bientôt à mon niveau
vous n'êtes donc pas contents de me voir
il nous faut l'arrêter au plus vite pour
empêcher le raid maroc la fin de toute
chose
donc je met sur pied une équipe
comme au bon vieux temps
surprise on va bien c'est aussi
[Musique]
salut
vrai guerrier
cinéma
sur la déesse de la mort
et toi de quoi était le dieu au juste
on se ressemble toi moi tout est brûlé
qui agissent sans réfléchir on est les
mêmes hulk comme le feu et or comme
boulot je dirais qu'on est tous les deux
comme le feu et le quai comme fleury et
or comme des petites breizh